WE HAVE THOSE ISSUES BUT WEIGHT
IS THE HOSTILITY IN THE
DEVELOPING SITUATION OUT OF IRAN
TONIGHT.
WE START WITH ANOTHER ADDITION
OF JERRY NADLER CLOWN SHOW ON
CAPITOL HILL.
AGAIN, AND OTHER CIRCUITS IN
CASE YOU HAVEN'T HEARD, NADLER'S
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HAVE STARTED
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS I GUESS
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP, FOR
WHAT?
HIGH CRIME, MISDEMEANORS, NOBODY
KNOWS, NOT EVEN HE KNOWS.
IT IS ONE BIG POLITICAL STUNT
NOTHING SHORT OF A PSYCHOTIC
RAGE, A HATRED THAT IS
NEVER-ENDING.
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY.
THE SIMPLE TRUTH IS, THERE ARE
NO HIGH CRIMES, THERE ARE NO
MISDEMEANORS, NO COLLUSION, NO
CONSPIRACY, NO OBSTRUCTION BUT
THE DOG AND PONY SHOW MUST GO O
ON.
THE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN NEEDS TO
APPEASE THE RADICAL EXTREME BASE
OF THIS NEW DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IF THAT MEANS DESTROYING THE
CAREERS OF HIS COLLEAGUES EVERY
OTHER HOUSE MEMBER AND MODERATE
DISTRICTS AND DISTRICTS
DONALD TRUMP WON THEY COULD CARE
LESS.
IT HURTS THE COUNTRY BUT SADLY
HE COULD CARRY THE LEFT.
LIKE SPEAKER NAME ONLY
NANCY PELOSI, NADLER IS
TERRIFIED OF THE SQUAD.
AND ALL THE OTHER EXTREME
SOCIALIST THAT ANNOUNCED DURING
THE SHIP OF THIS NEW EXTREME
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY.
AND TODAY, NADLER, FORMER TRUMP
CAMPAIGN MANAGER
COREY LEWANDOWSKI BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND COREY LEWANDOWSKI
HAS TESTIFIED BEFORE THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE NOT ONCE
BUT TWICE.
THE SENATE INTEL COMMITTEE FOR
EIGHT HOURS.
AND HE WAS INTERVIEWED BY
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER
WITCH HUNT TEAM FOR OVER 15
HOURS.
SO, JERRY, WHAT WAS THE POINT OF
TODAY'S TESTIMONY?
CLEARLY TODAY WAS NOT A
FACT-FINDING MISSION BUT
POLITICAL GRANDSTANDING
OPPORTUNITY BY A GROUP OF INAPT,
ANGRY DEMOCRATS, PEOPLE THAT
DON'T CARE ABOUT WE COME OF THE
PEOPLE, YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT FIGHTING FOR JOBS,
OR A SAFER WORLD, THEY ARE NOT
FIGHTING FOR MORE SECURITY IN
THE COUNTRY, NO, WHAT THEY ARE
FIGHTING ABOUT THE REAL ISSUES
FACING AMERICA, DONALD TRUMP
IMPEACHING FOR NO REASON, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> AT THE HOUSE AND OBSTRUCTION
OF CONGRESS ACROSS EVERY
COMMITTEE AND VIRTUALLY EVERY
INVESTIGATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE MR. MUELLER HERE.
, JUDGING BY ALL ACCOUNTS, IT
DID NOT GO WELL.
MORE OBSTRUCTION BY CONGRESS BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND YOU
FOLLOW INSTRUCTIONS AND YOU ARE
DOING EXACTLY WHAT YOU THOUGHT
THEY WERE DOING.
YOU ARE A LITTLE ALLELE -- WHALE
SOLDIER.
TO IMPACT THE ELECTION JIM COMEY
THAT VERY TABLE, SAID AFTER TEN
MONTHS OF INVESTIGATION WE
DIDN'T HAVE A THING.
BUT BOB MUELLER GETS NAME
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND WEIGHS
$30 MILLION IN TAX PAYER MONEY,
22 MONTH INVESTIGATION SET UP
THAT TABLE A FEW WEEKS AGO AND
GIVES THE SAME DARN ANSWER.
THESE GUYS OVER HERE, THEY DON'T
CARE.
>> PRESIDENT, YOU SHOULD BE HERE
TO BE TELLING THE TRUTH.
THE TRUTH WILL SET YOU FREE AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I YELLED BACK.
THE TIME OF THE CHANNEL LADY IS
EXPIRED AND HE MAY ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
>> I BELIEVE THERE WAS A
QUESTION, CONGRESSMAN.
>> YES, THERE WAS.
>> Sean: CHAIRMAN OF THE CLOWN
SHOW ON CAPITOL HILL AND IF
YOU'RE LISTENING I'M SURE YOU
WILL HEAR ABOUT IT, YOU SHOULD
KNOW THE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS ON
YOUR COMMITTEE, THEY PRETTY MUCH
LOOK AS DUMB AND STUPID AS YOU
DO EVERY DAY.
MEMBERS OF YOUR COMMITTEE, WELL,
THEY WERE HUMILIATED.
THEY WERE EMBARRASSED.
COREY LEWANDOWSKI OWNED THEM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AGAIN, CONGRESSWOMAN I
RECOGNIZE THE PRIVILEGE IS NOT
MINE BUT I'M ASKED BY THE
WHITE HOUSE AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION OR YOU
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION BY
YOURSELF BUT IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ASK ME A QUESTION.
>> THE REASON IS --
>> THIS IS A HOUSE JUDICIARY NOT
A HOUSE PARTY.
>> ARE YOU THE HIT MAN, THE
BAGMAN, THE LOOK OUT OR ALL OF
THE ABOVE?
>> I THINK I'M THE GOOD-LOOKING
MAN CAN ACTUALLY.
>> ARE YOU ASHAMED OF THE WORDS
YOU WROTE DOWN?
>> RESIDENTS WHILE WELL I'M VERY
HAPPY BUT YOU CAN READ IT IF YOU
LIKE.
IT IS PRETTY EASY -- >> Sean:
NOTHING BUT A JOKE, THE
IMPEACHMENT FANTASY, YES TO ALL
THE DEMOCRATS ON THE COMMITTEE,
IT IS OVER, IT'S NEVER GOING TO
HAPPEN, AND WHAT YOU ARE DOING
IS YOU ARE SHOWING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO YOU
REALLY ARE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE THIS
CHARADE FOR WHAT IT IS, BUT BY
ALL MEANS, MY ADVICE, KEEP
GOING.
DON'T GIVE UP.
KEEP GIVING THIS.
ALL OF YOUR OBSESSIVE,
COMPULSIVE RAGE, DON'T ALWAYS
GIVE INTO THE TEMPTATION.